citizens of the reject Nation we are
finally back after recouping from
getting the diesel and then we had to
catch up on Comic-Con everything that
presented for the week we're here with
Gravity Falls season two episode 10
halfway through this season and then
we're done goodbye Gravity Falls John
how are you doing I am terrific I'm
excited let's see what's going on leave
a like it doesn't take a lot of work do
it come on you can afford to put your
thumb to that button or scroll to to do
it we'll wait subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode is up
also full interaction watch as long as
we sync up with your own copy over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects
cover a bunch of shows over their
exclusive reaction highlights and Watch
Dogs included for several shows as well
and the prepper team thank you for
helping us set it down these highlights
already enough Chit Chat
the guest list for this year's party has
so much diversity yes a nice mix of
millionaires and billionaires work at an
angle we're not animals man now we're
the devil is Pacifica
the theme is seafoam green not Lake foam
green oh I kind of like it mind your
mother Pacifica but
yes Father good daughter oh no it's
happening
po poor people who pay me
this is a disaster the party's in just
24 hours surely there's someone who
could handle this sort of nonsense maybe
it's taxes I think I know just the
person
[Music]
hey Dipper's developing a reputation
yeah can make a living out of this an
entire 48-hour marathon of ghost
harassers on the used to be about
history
yup North wish family's annual High
Society shindig ball Soiree is here and
even though common folk aren't let in
that won't stop us from Canada
yep in case you've already forgotten
Pacifica Northwest is the worst and
that's not just jealousy talking I'd say
that to her face I need your help you're
the worst
look you think it's easy for me to come
here I don't want to be seen in this
hobble but there's something haunting
Northwest Manor if you don't help me the
party could be ruined oh no did you all
you've ever done is try to humiliate me
and Mabel then the mini golf episode you
help Pacifica you could give us invites
to the greatest party of all time this
is Pacifica we're talking about
imagination I'll bust your Ghosts change
I'll need three tickets to the party
you're just lucky I'm desperate
[Applause]
that's how I start my day desperate to
Sprint
West Manor dorks try not to touch
anything
empty floors fancy plant
fancy man yes very good list
hopefully you can help us with our
little situation before the guests
arrive in an hour Pacifica take our
guest to the problem room and uh he's
not wearing that it's the problem
[Laughter]
I'm pressing with this stuff
high standards are what make the
Northwest family rate oh wow guys it's
the guest list Marius Von fonthauser
I can't believe I'm gonna say this but I
think this boy is out of our league
Grandy's right he's a white whale
hunting him will destroy us let's swear
our sisters choose not to waste time on
Marius deal deal deal
haha you deceitful it is
[Music]
come on stupid thing there we go
oh nice Pacifica
oh wow that's freaky
[Music]
the category 10.
oh no what do we do
don't worry it can't get worse than this
wow cool
[Music]
read through your dumb book already I'm
[ __ ] and it's not dumb okay this book
is Gonna Save Our Life dream hipster
hey
welcome dukes and duchesses Sultans and
Sportsmen yo what up Presto you save 102
year old mayor of Gravity Falls mayor
beef Hunter
tonight we will enjoy only the finest of
tastes and only the snootiest of
laughter
that's the ticket
candy listen to me carefully you're
caught in a sweet Savory Loop put the
fondue Fork down
I want to but I can't love a good fondue
[Music]
Guten Tag
couldn't take me now
listen Mabel I don't know if I can
follow this truth he is too adorable oh
me too candy but what do we do he's
unattainable
it is the perfect plan but what about
Grenda I love Grenda Mabel but these
see how aggressive flirting style might
scare them away I'm rooting for Grenda
[Music]
oh that's a Bo Burnham
oh there's a silver mirror right there
is it real this
this is my parents favorite carpet
shoes off
you wouldn't understand
that's weird I don't even know where
this room is yeah maybe we're safe
uh Freddy
did it work
[Music]
Ed
oh
okay can I pay you to pretend that never
happened leaving
already you're at the world's best party
dummy I'd love to stay but I've got a
category 10 ghost to dispose of
what are you laughing about man I
defeated you you've been had
but mind me of me 150 years
and what
we were told would be a service to the
town that once a year they would throw a
grand party and all would share in the
Bounty it took years of back-breaking
labor but when it was time for the grand
party they promised the common folk of
the town they thought you used to let us
in they were had classism with the trees
done the mudslides began I was Swept
Away by the storms
oh god wow
a curse passed down until this day the
Northwest knew this haunting was coming
and they tricked me into helping them to
avoid ghostly Justice uh
let's take this chimp servant keep him
away from Bright Lights he gets grabby
kind of sounds like Nathan Fillion all
you had to do was let the town spoke
into the party and you could have broken
the curse but you
but you said look at who you're talking
to boy I'm hosting a party for the most
powerful people in the world do you
think they come here
enjoy the party it's the last time you
and your kind will ever come
no no those aren't for him
stupid northwests making me do their
exorcism for them Exodus demoness
spookascaris ain't afraid of snow
ghosters
much as I
it's just my sister's in there and you
seem a little unstable man very well
uh I guess go nuts man
oh no
oh no
[Music]
gotta get the big mirror man
hi I'm Mabel so Australia huh
[Music]
if you are a boat do you know what kind
you'd be a dream boat that's what kind
you are ticked out head back in you
can't do that I can take myself it's
allowed
Timothy shallow may come back you've got
something on your shirt
[Music]
I knew it he's kinky thank you
overcoming I think we can all say this
party was a rousing success I guess you
could say it was a slam dunk Preston yes
yes I guess sure
Generations locked away my revenge shall
have its day ah the Grim Reaper I've
been wondering when you would arrive oh
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
just make it a Halloween party
the Panic Room
it's like Jumanji just because you're
your parents daughter doesn't mean you
have to be like them it's not too late
no no no no no no
[Applause]
let the guess in pull that lever and
open the grand gate to the town fulfill
your ancestors promise Pacifica at least
Northwest stop this instant
now come into the Panic Room there's
enough mini sandwiches and oxygen to
last you me at a butler full week we'll
eat the butler
you dare disobey us
fight it our family name is broken and
I'm gonna fix it
[Laughter]
get it
or something
you are not like the other northwests I
feel Lumber Justice
[Music]
no no kill him golly
glow the Riff rack they're everywhere
next year I'm sure they're just gonna
lock everyone out again guess what we're
standing on huh
[Music]
oh
but seriously I'd better go find someone
to clean this up
[Music]
whoa what's up McGucket hey oh
the apocalypse the end times
you know what McGucket how about we talk
about this stuff tomorrow it's a party
let's have some fun for once huh hey
oh this is bad
something's coming something big
[Music]
they're seeing activity on the machine
it's go time where's my phone I asked
you when we were in the car why do we
always have to fight at parties not even
gonna ask haha
awkward situation all right
that was a good episode it really showed
us how the poorer of just repulsive just
annoying degenerates who would just
wreck everything because
they don't lack any class
disgusting and I'm glad that this show
finally exposed just how horrible
most of the people in this world are
disgusting human beings Vermin of
society yeah it's a good way to put it
John the Vermin of society the weak
the folly
the middle class and under I'm glad that
the the rich you know you get some Jabs
at them but it's they they don't go
overboard they're able to take the piss
out of them you know like yeah it's it's
funny they're doing us all a favor they
can take it you see like the rich know
how to laugh at themselves we know how
to do it and I thought it was
hilarious
hilarious stuff so yeah no that's not my
sincere thought uh I thought it was a
really really well told episode well
told episode really fun and uh Pacifica
they started having us come around to
her in that mini golf episode and then
in this episode
became very likable extremely likable
first it was Mabel endearing herself to
Pacifica now it's Dipper looking like he
might catch some feels some attraction
Dipper Mary into that [ __ ] what would
your uncle do who we didn't see at all
in this episode once but what would he
do he would totally go after it get all
that money oh yeah dude dude dude what
about your hairs of who she is yeah live
out your Jane Austen novel fantasies of
marrying outside your own class you know
that'd be amazing yeah dude that'd be
amazing but no I thought that they they
really did
capture that chemistry well and then you
know also there is a classism divide as
well demonstrated in this episode and I
I do like Jabs at the elite showing just
how insensitive they are
and uh I thought that was a really
funny way to do it and I thought the arc
for Pacifica was very natural it got
really horrific and spooky spooky spooky
fun house stuff yeah it was very spooky
this was another one of the this was
what I appreciate about certain things
is when you know like this was a 23 24
minute episode but it felt longer than
that in a good way like sometimes you're
like oh man I wish there could have been
more to that but this was it was longer
it was longer it was like 24 minutes
right yeah but uh it was a little bit
longer and like a minute longer and they
trimmed they shortened the intro true
that so I felt like we got a lot of
benefits of that review completed uh
yeah I thought I felt like they we got a
lot of the benefits that we got this
wasn't one of a few episodes where I'm
like oh wow they're they're really going
for that like younger that like pushing
the top range of that young teen
audience this was originally pitched at
which I always appreciate I feel like uh
horror that is accessible to young
people that's like actually kind of
scary is you know fewer and farther
between now than it used to be and so
like when all the Taxidermy heads are
like
I I was expecting them to
recontextualize it but now there's
bleeding from the eyes and from the
mouths and stuff like that I was like oh
wow they really weren't afraid to go
there with this and yeah it creates on
top of you know the already interesting
and fun lore that Gravity Falls has it
adds an extra edge of like oh this could
actually have some lasting impacts or
this could actually get kind of you know
harsh or or something you know not not
like extremely but you know for this
show certainly and that's always a
really fun Rush when you have an episode
like that that's like really going for
it and I just love the the mythology and
uh you know the sordid history of
Gravity Falls and the way that that
manifests in the spirit and two it's the
way he like turns them all into wood and
you know the Mansion is like engulfed in
foliage it's really a lovely imagery I
agree yeah I agree wholeheartedly and
that's gonna be my new flirting
technique just hey you got some on your
shirt
[Music]
yeah I think what this show and lately
has been doing is
um uprooting you know just finding out
as you unpack the lore you start finding
out like the in a lot of ways it shows
like stranger things meets Gotham
set in Twin Peaks yeah yeah yeah yeah
Twin Peaks is actually a much better
pull than anything I said uh so yeah I
think that's what they've been doing
because you're also seeing all the
secret societies and especially
controlled by the wealthy people uh I'm
enjoying it it's really good it's really
good and uh the characters are solid
Grenda gotta win predictable as hell but
it was a good win about time she
actually snags a hand and we have no
Zeus either
no he's missing he was God they both got
a vacay this week but you know maybe
next time it'll be all about them maybe
John maybe but hey before we end this
leave a like subscribe tell us your
thoughts down below and let's do a
patreon
what do you got John Fox Say completely
different thing [ __ ] man in a woodland
environment such as Gravity Falls you
would be right at home as some kind of
hybrid humanoid Fox creature which I
think would also blend really well with
a show like this given you know the
overlapping Venn diagram with like the
furry community
and uh you know the the the general uh
Slash Fick cartoon communities found
online I feel like you could find
yourself a really great Niche being that
sort of a character uh you know and then
you could be like uh you know you could
be like our Mabel you know you could
join us and uh you know bring your
unique attitude as we go adventuring and
solving Mysteries and whatnot you know
you'd have a good quip you'd have your
unflappable attitude and also a tail and
ears like a fox because in this fantasy
you are a humanoid human fox hybrid uh
you know just like the government used
to be afraid they were going to try and
make because of stem cell research
well jokes on them [ __ ]
yep those are all new sentiments I think
I think he did an excellent job thanks
man I miss you fox we love you stay well
well done
thanks man
[Music]